on reste dans l'éducation avec le
premier séminaire du pôle de recherche
et d'enseignement supérieur de
l'université paris-x grant west on
quitte l'enseignement primaire cette
fois ci c'était à saint germain en laye
il ya quelques jours à l'occasion de
préciser les objectifs de cette mise en
commun de moyens de 17 établissements de
75 laboratoire des yvelines et du val
d'oise rencontre tout d'abord avec la
présidente de ce presse bourgault comme
il faut l'appeler sylvie faucheux le
pressent signifia pôle de recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur donc de
l'université paris-x grant west go en
fait c'est la fédération de la quasi
totalité on va dire des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
des yvelines et du val d'oise
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un presse
un presse c'est là pour apporter de la
valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire pour pouvoir
développer les projets que chacun des
établissements membres n'auraient pas pu
faire seul
par exemple un institut d'études
politiques un institut de la création
dont on parle aujourd'hui est donc un
presse c'est aussi là pour pouvoir
développer des projets et participez au
développement de territoire il ya un
maillage très fort avec un territoire au
niveau d'un presse
et puis de pouvoir travailler en
synergie avec les acteurs socio
économiques du territoire étaient dans
cet esprit par exemple que nous sommes
en train de développer un institut
d'efficacité énergétique et des énergies
renouvelables sur les mureaux où un
institut de la logistique verte dans la
confluence
donc on voit que un press c'est vraiment
un outil qui va permettre de demeurer
youn et davantage qui va permettre de
développer des nouveaux projets aussi
bien pour les établissements membres que
pour les collectivités territoriales de
notre bassin donc aujourd'hui sur saint
germain en laye c'est le séminaire
inaugural vous lancer véritablement les
activités ça va consister en quoi
aujourd'hui
les discussions qui vont avoir lieu
alors aujourd'hui c'est le séminaire
inaugural effectivement donc nous avons
été créés et donc par décret en février
dernier donc vraiment nos instances de
gouvernance ont été consolidées en
juillet dernier donc on a lancé des
projets et le séminaire inaugurale qui
est un vrai succès puisqu'on a refusé
pas mal de participants ou non ne seront
plus de 300 quand même
et bien ce séminaire inaugurale a pour
objectif
de pouvoir échanger au niveau de la
communauté académique et c'est vraiment
destinée en interne communauté des
enseignants chercheurs et aussi des
équipes des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche
pouvoir échanger sur les projets déjà
mis en route sur donner des idées sur de
nouveaux projets pouvoir donner des
idées sur des mutualisations donc ça va
aussi bien de la discussion projet très
très lent c'est comme l'institut
d'études politiques
l'institut confucius institut de la
création d'un institut d et
internationale est avancé comme sur des
projets qui sont plus en cour plus en
gestation comme par exemple le
regroupement des écoles d'ingénieurs
donc pour constituer une vraie force
comme le collegium des iut mais aussi
sur des projets nouveaux comme le
portail unique pour la documentation
comme un des programmes de réussite pour
les étudiants comme des programmes d'éco
campus partagez donc on est vraiment là
pour faire le point pour pouvoir ont
cédé aux lancers des synergies pour pour
permettre en fait au plus grand nombre
de participer un plus haut plus vaste
par un très grand nombre aux six projets
et première réalisation concrète de ce
pôle de recherche un institut d'études
politiques il devrait ouvrir à la
rentrée 2013 à saint-germain-en-laye
justement les explications alors ça fait
deux ans que le projet est né il sera
accueilli dans les locaux de saint
germain en laye de l'iufm de saint
germain en laye et il est à
il est très avancé puisque nous
attendons les derniers accords
ministériel pour ouvrir l'institut
d'études politiques donc très
prochainement
l'institut d'études politiques j'allais
dire encore un institut d'études
politiques on a l'impression qu'il a
beaucoup justement quelle quelle va être
la force de celui ci
maintenant il y en a moins d'une dizaine
dans ses pas beaucoup quand on voit le
nombre de candidatures qui lie apparent
au concours d'entrée en première année
on se dit qu'il ya une très forte
demande et très peu d'offres il faut
ajouter aussi le fait que cette offre
elle essentiellement à par l'institut
d'études politiques de paris centre
elle est essentiellement situés en
région le plus proche de paris de la
région parisienne c'est lille donc il ya
clairement un manque en ile de france
donc quelle sera la force justement de
cet institut d'études politiques c'est
déjà d'avoir été créé dans le cadre de
synergies avec beaucoup d'acteurs
différents
voilà ce sont deux universités qui
mettent toutes leurs forces en commun
pour animer cette ce nouvel institut
donc toutes les disciplines enseignées
dans les instituts d'études politiques
sont représentés nous avons nos
collègues anciennement enseignants
chercheurs qui vont qui vont
donner des cours dans ces dans cet
institut l'autre atout c'est une volonté
de d'être très clairement ancré dans
l'internationale avec le soutien de
partenaires locaux comme le lycée
international de saint germain qui va
nous permettre d'offrir un choix de
langue beaucoup plus important que la
plupart des autres instituts d'études
politiques à pala ya aussi une volonté
très forte de participer au processus de
démocratisation de l'entrée dans ce type
d'institution par la mise en place de
préparation dans des proportions
gratuite ou pratiquement très peu
coûteuse dans les enseignements dans les
lycées publics d'île de france et
notamment dans les dents dans les
quartiers les plus populaires
comment ça va fonctionner ses relations
pour permettre à ses étudiants qui peut
être n'aurait pas pensé pouvoir intégrer
un institut d'études politiques des dix
arrivées en terminale es en première on
met en place un dispositif un
partenariat avec délice et voilà situées
dans des communes plus populaire que les
autres et on a des relais les
professeurs d'histoire ou de philosophie
prennent en charge avec des
universitaires cette préparation et
préparent pendant un ou deux ans des
étudiants qui des lycéens qui n'auraient
pas pensé
si on n'avait pas été les chercher a
préparé ce type de concours
voilà ils en espèrent voilà on espère
accueillir presque 20 % de boursiers à
l'issue de de la mise en place de ce
dispositif âme le 7-8 toujours en direct
entre 18 et 19 heures nous faisons le
point sur l'actualité du jour dans le
département principalement autour de
saint quentin en yvelines et de
versailles dans un instant la chronique
de l'innovation comme chaque mardi
dorénavant avec valérie auribeau elle
dépister pour mieux soigner vous le
savez se déroule actuellement le mois
d'information sur le dépistage du cancer
du sang un cancer qui touche 50 3000
femmes en france chaque année va
pourtant plus la maladie est détecté tôt
plus les chances de guérison sont
grandes dans le cadre de cette campagne
de sensibilisation un spectacle
parapluie rose vient d'avoir lieu à
trappes reportage de catherine mulato et
d'élodie moines
c'est vrai que j'adore rire et blaguer
mais il ya des moments il faut savoir
être sérieux surtout quand il s'agit du
cancer du sein
si vous êtes une femme de plus de 50 ans
vous allez recevoir une lettre pour
faire dépister
prenez rendez vous vous avez peut-être
vu cette publicité diffusée en ce moment
nagui qui se prononcent pour le
dépistage du cancer du sein
une campagne nationale pour inciter les
femmes entre 50 et 74 ans a bénéficié du
dépistage gratuit et sur le terrain une
mobilisation également locales comme ici
à trappes
avec l'opération des parapluies rose on
invite les femmes à se faire dépister
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçoit qu'en
dans les yvelines
on est un département où 41 % seulement
des femmes participent à ce dépistage
organisé
donc il ya des gens qui sont réticents
il y en a qui quand il y en a qui ont
peur parce que le cancer est un mot qui
fait peur donc tout on essaye simplement
de dédramatiser et de leur dire que
justement avec le avec le dépistage
c'est pas forcément la maladie cc c'est
justement en en s'y prenant parfois tôt
qu'un cancer et déplie cancer est
dépisté tôt pour mieux on le soigne des
comédiens sont donc venus raconter des
histoires pour faire passer un seul
message détecté tôt 90% des cancers du
sein sont guéris avec près de cinquante
trois mille nouveaux cas chaque année le
cancer du sein est le cancer le plus
fréquent chez la femme dans les yvelines
un centre de coordination est basé au
chesnay